[Music]
oh
cindy you are 14 years old and
very busy planning your life but here's
the secret
you can't always plan the unexpected
will happen
and take you in directions you never
dreamed
when you meet a man at a cocktail party
who intrigues you
beyond all reason follow your heart
i was on a flight over the city
of hanoi at first you won't know
anything about him
or his heroic military history
only that he looks very handsome in his
dress white uniform
soon his intellect and understanding of
world events
will leave you awed right now
you don't think much about politics
and you might even laugh at the idea of
knocking on 14
000 doors to help your husband win
his first campaign for congress
election night 1982 but it will happen
and you will love every moment years
from now when you and your husband
become well known
your fear of making a mistake will be
misread
as aloofness keep your warm spirit
and don't let anyone else define you
dare to be an original
you've grown up in the west living a
very privileged life in phoenix
and you will even become the junior
rodeo queen of arizona
you imagine arizona is forever your home
but when you have a chance to go
somewhere else
embrace the adventure first it will be
college in california
and after you get married you will try
life on the opposite coast
know that you have choices if you want
to do the unexpected
like raising your children in arizona
while your husband works in washington
dc
have faith in yourself no matter how
intimidating the decision
[Music]
not everything will be perfect though in
the early
1990s you became addicted to painkillers
i did some things that i'm ashamed of
and that were very
wrong at the time you will fall into the
crisis of
addiction that has sunk so many people
leading to mistakes that cause you pain
and even
deep despair but you will pull out
and gain courage and strength to move
forward
always remember though addiction
is a very cunning enemy
try to live a life of service to others
as you take trips to many parts of the
globe
you will have a deep urge to relieve the
suffering you encounter
you will start a medical charity to help
people in times of crises
and on one trip to bangladesh you will
meet an
infant who won't survive without your
help
you will bring her home to become a part
of your own family
a joyous addition to your three natural
children
something crazy may happen in your life
like the man you love decides to run
for president of the united states
after he wins the nomination of the
republican party
you will spend months together on the
campaign trail
give it everything you have it's okay to
fall short of a goal if you've enjoyed
every moment along the way take pride in
your country
you won't always agree with the
direction it's going
and you will have bad days as you watch
certain leaders
take regrettable positions believe
though
that democracy will right itself and
that the ideals of our country are
strong
however uncomfortable you may feel speak
out when you see something wrong i want
you to know
how deeply honored i am to endorse you
oh you have
no idea what it means don't leave it to
other people to lead
you will regularly encounter people who
want to undermine you
stay strong greatness happens
when you're willing to stand up and
believe in yourself
most of all fill your days with
adventures
and know that the family you build will
be the source of
endless happiness and pride even at one
of your
darkest moments
[Music]
when the man who brought you so much
happiness and laughter
is taken away by a vicious disease
your family will be a source of strength
in every day find time to experience
joy to make a difference in the world
and to be a source of love and hope and
caring to your family and friends
understand that sometimes it takes a
while to find your own voice
it's there inside of you
ready to be heard god bless you cindy